this video is shot a little bit
differently than my previous course
lecture videos i have two ethics courses
and what i'm doing now with these videos
is recording both lecture and discussion
and group work sessions
and then taking sort of the best hits of
of both of them and stitching them
together so you'll see a little bit of
repetition
in this video
in the two sessions from today
i began both of them by starting the
class doing a group exercise that had to
do with the conventional theory of
justice that
that paula marcus uh
focused on that divides the world
essentially into friends and enemies and
says that justice is doing good to
friends doing evil to to enemies and so
we came together as a class the first
class and the second class
and compiled some lists which you'll see
in just a moment
and then we talked about some of the
weaknesses of the theory but the lists
are very interesting and each class came
up with a quite different lists
the only other thing which is divided in
this in one class i ended the class by
talking about one argument that socrates
provides against thrasymachus's might
makes right position
and in the other class i focused on the
other argument there's two main
arguments that he uses to attack the
position
so i divided the class time into both
and you'll see that towards the end of
this video
so so we have this this whole marcus
conventional
uh you know the world is divided up into
friends and enemies
um kind of moral mentality that we find
widespread
um
oftentimes it helps to try to relate
this to our own life and our society
think about who we have as friends who
what did you guys have down this
practice
um
partners when they become enemies then
you got to get divorced or somebody's
got to kill some
so
that's what we make movies on right
should we list all of them sure
teammates yeah
um
housemates
how about you guys what else um we had
like almost all those okay and then we
also have like co-workers
um
okay
co-workers classmates classmates
um
what did you guys have yeah
okay so some character traits did you
guys have character traits as well
so trustworthy
honest loyalty
well you know those are a lot of the
things that the other
class had as well
so we'll put trustworthy
trust
loyal
uh honest
i think a lot of those traits we put in
good things because right what we do i
think you're right yeah
from them as well okay though
um
trust
loyalty
honesty that's actually a really good
point notice that one of the things
that we use to define a friend is
on the basis of what they give us we
want to get the same thing from them as
we're giving to them and vice versa if
somebody's
honest to us we tend to feel like we
want to be honest to them we'd be unjust
to be dishonest
what about enemies we'll come back to
good things in a moment um what did you
guys have for enemies
i like the descriptive uh
these are not all uh mutually exclusive
too right
competitors okay
okay
how about you guys what did you have um
we had a lot of those then we also had
like killers and criminals
okay
we'll include killers and criminals
because
um
the opposite of our allies right um
should we put someone who would try to
prevent you from achieving your goal
uh let's call those
impediments
people who are
what did you
okay well these are pretty pretty robust
lists actually um and you notice you can
and a lot of people do divide the world
up into friends and enemies
and they they follow this sort of
viewpoint and they say you know my
friends deserve the best for me my
enemies deserve the worst for me
if you
catch somebody else you know helping out
an enemy and say what the hell is wrong
with you why are you helping them out
they're a bad person how do you know
they're a bad person they're they're an
enemy look at they fit into this list
they do the kind of things that enemies
do
you know
let's start with bad things though
what are some bad things you think
enemies deserve
karma
what do you mean
isolation
okay that's an interesting one isolation
well it could be in many terms like
whether jail or isolation from society
or from your friends and yourself a lot
of people in the other class that you
know they should be ignored
i brought up in the other class the
practice of shunning which is done in
some some religious communities that are
non-violent
it's a way of
taking offenders and
you know getting them out of the
area you just don't you don't deal with
them
what else what are some other
bad some bad things that bad people
deserve
failure okay
yeah i guess depending on where you are
and this was the extreme that i said for
killers maybe death for them depending
where you are
uh let's say harm you know we could make
it a spectrum
um
if you're if you're
not a killer but you heard a lot of
other people maybe we hurt you you know
bullies maybe they should get yeah
um
that's curbs the bullying um
like
justice when justice is a bad thing in
terms of like punishment and injustice
when
injustice affects
the enemies in a negative way
so
uh not being treated fairly
maybe not being able to have access to
the same protection as
other people do
you know one argument that gets made
about about um
prisons
is that you know people say well
conditions are very bad we ought to
improve the conditions
and in some prison systems they are
quite quite bad
and then somebody will come along and
say hey it's prison
it's supposed to
be an awful place
so that would that would be this sort of
idea right yeah
what was interesting was to see
prisoners
taking the position of saying yeah this
is prison this ought to be this yeah i
feel like that happens a lot whereas
people outside of the jail are kind of
fighting for those inside and there
people on the inside are kind of saying
well i deserve this i'll tell you um
one thing that two things i realized
when i was teaching in the indianapolis
and so i can only generalize about that
because
each prison system is a different sort
of animal
most of the guys that i dealt with and
this is a maximum security would say i'm
not innocent neither are those guys
the other thing was that there were two
sets of stories or two faces one was for
judges reporters chaplains volunteers
you know sympathetic ears and then there
was the
inside talking with the guys who really
mattered
sort of thing and a prisoner might
present themselves as i'm just a victim
here
to
this group and then you know be much
more honest when it comes to the guys
that they actually live with and
interact with on a daily basis um so
that's just sort of an aside
because yeah a better place for them to
be also
yeah they actually get food and
they have a bag
and free education
yeah yeah they call it three hots in a
cot well
most prisons don't have free education
these days not college education
there's about 11 states that have it
it's unfortunate too because the best
way to cut down on people going back
recidivism turns out to be
earning a college degree
in prison but it's expensive
it's unpopular so well let's let's get
away from the prison to get back to good
things now what are some good things
that your friends
want to get from you or you ought to
give them that bad thing real quick sure
embarrassment
oh
uh
let's say this is just a shame
okay yeah yeah the the sanction of a
public disapproval um and what are some
good things
what's that
favors okay
affection
what's that affection affection yeah
that's very important
somebody might you know say they're your
friend but if they treat you
you know unaffectionately maybe they're
you're actually your enemy
um what else
okay yeah
that's a friendly thing to do
it's good yeah
support
support um
that came up in the other class as well
i think that's very important actually
um
one of the ways in which you can tell
who your genuine friends are is they do
support you when you run into
difficulties that's why we that's why we
need friends and family and
other support
now let's think about this for a minute
so these are really good
these are
this shows that you guys can wrap your
heads around this this way of thinking
quite easily
what are some of the problems with
looking at the world this way
there's really two main problems and
they both have to do
with um
knowledge
have you ever been wrong about about
these
in your life
um a lot of people are right or if you
somebody has somebody been wrong about
where you fit into these classes
have you ever experienced that you ever
been treated like an enemy
when you're really somebody's
friend
what's going on there socrates points
out to paul marcus he says
sometimes people are deluded about who
the good and the bad people actually are
and they think that somebody's
they're friends and if we identify
friends just with all these classes
think about this are all of your
teachers
your friends
could some of them possibly be your
enemies
yeah how about uh housemates
anyone ever had a bad roommate
you know somebody who stole or cheated
or you know
seduced your boyfriend or girlfriend or
you know pick all sorts of things
ruined your credit right are all of your
classmates and co-workers
because they're in your your group
are they necessarily your friends or
might they actually be
competitors with you or even
backstabbers or bullies or belittlers
you know these these categories
are a bit too
crude sometimes
and
people end up getting hurt because they
they make assumptions well somebody fits
in these classes they must be
my friends and i'll treat them well and
they will treat me well in return and
then that doesn't happen
right
or
they automatically assume that somebody
over here
must be an enemy
there's two ways to go wrong with this
if somebody doesn't share a lot of
things in common with you if you have
this sort of mentality it's very easy to
fall into us people who are similar and
then the people who are dissimilar and
us we owe each other a lot of nice
things and we'll treat each other well
but screw those other people we don't
owe them anything as a matter of fact
they better not start competing with us
or get in our way because they're bad
some of them are genuinely bad
somebody's really a terrorist you know
the whole point of terrorism is to
strike fear into the hearts of people by
doing horrible things to them they
clearly belong in there
terrorists are your enemies
by definition
um
are all of our allies our friends
nope yeah we're having a rough time
sometimes with some of our supposed
allies aren't we
france just halted all of its uh
work in afghanistan because one of the
supposedly afghan forces on our side
killed a bunch of french soldiers
clearly
in the enemy not the
krem category it's easy to get mixed up
about these sort of things
so it's easy to get mixed up about who
we actually owe these things to so this
is not going to be
that reliable of a
moral theory for deciding what's right
and what's wrong
but it is one that a lot of people use
isn't it it's a starting point
let's look at another one now we'll look
at through symmetrical
so if we're looking at
the way that paul marcus is talking
about justice we've got um
these basic categories
and i had to do this group exercise or
you know thinking about what falls under
these because you know the
book itself
the republic doesn't go into any great
depth about this but if you wanted to
apply this kind of theory as people do
in their ordinary life
then you'd have to do a bit more
thinking about what are the specifics of
this what falls under this
so um friends and enemies you do have to
if you're a pole marcus you do divide
the world up until two classes
um
who
falls under friends so what did you guys
have what what does your group have
uh we said someone who treats you well
and gives you respect
okay
people in your family or on your sports
team
is your respect
okay so
um people like
what did your group have
um we said that friends are people you
enjoy being around okay spending time
with
uh enjoy it
um and that there are people that you
have
um
did you share common things that's so
similar to what they were saying before
you share common experiences
yeah we often talk about this in terms
of like bonding right you go through
basic training together
you're in the same class at marist okay
what did your group have
um we people who are trustworthy ah
that's an important trait
okay
honesty
i think i might have to move this
okay so
this is a good composite
picture of
people you'd like to be friends with
what you hope your friends would be like
or your family people that you're close
with
they might have one of these
characteristics at first and then you
know you find out that they have others
um
what makes people mad people what makes
them your enemies why don't we start
with this group
and then people that you don't have that
commonality
with okay so like i guess different
um
okay so you guys probably don't have a
lot of enemies
all right at least not that you realize
uh what did you guys have
for enemies
oh um you like competition kind of like
people you're going against yeah
competition could make this enemies
i don't know if you guys had a
discussion about that over there
um
you could have like you said friendly
competition i heard somebody mention
that there but oftentimes
competition does bring out the worst of
us
and it leads to a very
sorry us versus that mentality so think
about athletic sports you know teammates
it's pretty easy to start looking at the
other team as the bad guys
bless you
fans do this you know
by all right i should you know be really
angry with the giants because they knock
my team out of the contention for the
super bowl although i don't actually you
know
i really do like my team but i don't
really care that much about
the team that knocked them out so i
might
but you know quite a few people probably
would
you've seen fanatic sports fans what
else about
someone who's like self-centered
okay yeah um
and there's some opposition between
being self-centered
and having some of these other
friendly characteristics like loyalty
being trustworthy
treating you with respect
treating you well often times when
people are self-centered they because
they make themselves the center of
things they make exceptions for
themselves and they they don't treat
other people well right yeah we also
said jealousy
oh that's interesting
because you know the jealous person
you know there's a difference between
envy and jealousy jealousy is like when
you
don't want somebody else talking with
your boyfriend or girlfriend
being envious is when you want what
somebody else
has and the jealous person
acts like an enemy right certainly
towards the person that they want to
keep away but oftentimes towards the
person that they
they are jealous of
um
but they think that they're being
super friendly don't they
so there's there's sometimes an
interplay there what did you
uh we said not only the people that
treat you badly but the people that
treat your friends
oh that's very
interesting so once you've actually got
this circle established anybody who
attacks that circle
sort of like you're going to mess with
my little brother you're messing with me
what else
um just in general people that have
different views on what's great as well
oh
okay so it's not just that they're
different in
any old way they have
different
use of right and wrong
which again
goes to
the problem of loyalty
or treating you with respect
if somebody thinks that
if they buy you dinner they can do
anything they want they can act like a
jerk
that's a very different understanding of
right and wrong than i think most of you
have right
there are people who act like that so
they would place themselves in the class
of your
your enemies
what are some of the good things that
you get from friends or you would like
them to give you or you would give them
what are the things that
help build up that interplay yeah
second chances that's very interesting
or often we say the benefit of the doubt
right
looks like they might be doing something
wrong ah
they're your friends so you'll then
trust them
what else
and sacrifices are always sacrifices of
other
good things
right so
if for somebody who's in your family you
give a lot of your time
um
like you know you've got grandpa in the
old folks home and so you go and see him
every
week and you spend you know
three four hours there that's really
behaving in a friendly way right you're
sacrificing some goods of your own you
could be at home
playing xbox
doing homework talking on the phone with
your other friends
doing all sorts of things right so when
you say when we talk about sacrifice
we're always talking about sacrificing
some other thing that we consider good
if you didn't really want what you were
supposedly sacrificing it's not much of
a sacrifice is it
so
what are some goods that you guys had
um
like giving back like the same
friendship that they get to us like
being kind and respectful to them okay
that's important too kindness
respect
you'd probably do that with some of
these other qualities like honesty and
loyalty
um
generosity maybe would fit in there
um what did you guys have um we said
like supporting one another like having
that kind of support system between
friends like either for you or from you
yeah you know that's a good point and
that probably
ties in with a lot of these things that
involves some sacrifices that involves
these these qualities that you see as
kind of
friendliness with the friend relation
what about over here with enemies bad
things
what sort of bad things should you pay
out to enemies i mean adam mantis is
thinking it's okay if you kill them
burn their houses down
they're your enemies
uh what do we don't none of you are
burning houses down i hope or
killing people or
poisoning their their wells or um
destroying their bank accounts or
anything like that
what are some of the things that we
might
do in our ordinary we might be like rude
to them or
ignore them
yeah sometimes i can really get to
somebody too canton um
there are some communities that are
non-violent and the way that they
enforce their rules is by shunning
people
so they won't have anything to do with
you if you're if you're not following
the norms
what else what are other ways what are
other
sanctions or reprisals we might commit
which by the way this this point of view
says a-okay you know enemies have it
coming to them
what did you get
insulting
um
what did you guys get
uh well we said payless attention which
is basically foreign
or mentally sure
if you think about us as groups you know
there are some people that we
at least our society think it's okay to
harm
um
we're fighting wars right
fighting's about killing
um
even within our own society we have
police who are authorized to use deadly
force who were they supposed to use
deadly force against
anybody they like
hopefully not who are they supposed to
use
force against breaking the law yeah
lawbringers criminals and they're
supposed to do so in order to protect
the
the innocent who would fall under
friends
and if you you know with this certain
point of view if you cross over into the
realm of enemies by behaving like an
enemy
by being a bad person
then it's fair game
you know
now you know this could lead to certain
tragic effects you can you can have
cases where
say families
fight each other
or teams get very rough with each other
because they're all friends so they get
along with each other but the other
group they don't get along with them
and this is one of the problems that
socrates points out
you notice that with both enemies and
friends you guys were able to give some
criteria
what makes an enemy what makes a
a friend
how do you know if you've got it right
this is one of the problems socrates is
raising with with
this way of looking at things
have you ever had the experience of
thinking somebody was your friend
and then you find out actually they're
not
one bet every single one of you has
right
have you ever had the experience of
seeing somebody as an enemy at first
and maybe even you know you have some
interplay with them of this sort you
know insulting each other but then you
find out actually
they're a good person and then you
become friends later on
i know i've had a lot like that because
i was kind of a mean guy when i was your
age
even through graduate school
and got into a lot of arguments and
luckily not any physical altercations
but
i'm friends with a lot of people now
that i would never consider friends
we even have a term for people that are
they seem to be your friends but are
actually your enemies
what do we call those
push two words together
frenemies right and those are the people
that they're in your circle but they're
actually secretly undermining you the
whole time
that's one of the problems with this
this point of view is
it can lead us to treat the wrong people
as friends or as enemies it's not a
completely coherent
moral point of view
but it is you know it's one that a lot
of people adopt isn't it
this is a decent starting point because
at least here you do have some
conceptions of what good things are
what bad things are what you want to see
in a person what you don't want to see
in a person
the enemy would be
ideally somebody who's unjust wouldn't
they
are all of your enemies unjust
by this probably not
because just because somebody
doesn't have commonalities with you
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
actually a bad person
you just don't
share certain things in common
um being self-centered probably does
make them a bad person
right
somebody you don't enjoy being around
are there people who are good for you
that you don't enjoy being around
some of your
teachers throughout you know your your
career
as a student later on you realize well
they were really tough on me but
it's been to my benefit
they were actually
your friend but he probably looked at
him as an enemy i know i did
i was
in grade school
so there are some problems with this
point of view let's look at the next
point to do that
so that's that's a
sort of a conventional
kind of morality now we're going to turn
morality on top
as i said in the the intro to this video
uh in both class sessions we discussed
one argument that socrates makes in
republic book one against thrasymachus's
position so now you're going to see
those two arguments the first one
focuses on the nature of knowledge and
crafts and skills and the second one
focuses on
whether unjust people can actually
function together now we're going to
turn morality on attack
we've got this guy traceemicus
and what can you say about that
if you had to describe it to somebody
else
yeah i'll definitely definitely say he's
like more of an enemy he's like he kind
of sees like
unjust as
being a better route to take
yeah and how does he actually treat
socrates
how does he talk to him i think he's
completely wrong
yeah he goes a little bit beyond just
saying i think you've got it wrong
uh yeah
he insults socrates i mean socrates is
an older man this is a society where age
actually counts and he's treating a guy
who's twice his age as if he's a little
kid he says you know you need a nurse to
wipe your nose
you know
he's being a jerk
um he is acting like an enemy you guys
are you guys are right and he does um to
use that thing about
friends have the same sort of moral
point of view enemies have a different
moral point of view he is treating
everybody else's of their enemies
because they have the mistaken point of
view and he's the only one who's
got it right
and he says
here's one of the things he says
justice is the advantage
of the
stronger
that's kind of a strange thing to say
isn't it
if you had to define justice would you
come up with that definition
what does he mean
he has to clarify his position as time
goes on yeah he means like um
he uses like thieves and stuff for
example like they steal and get like
rich so they're like in power against
money and stuff
yeah um he thinks that in any society
you've got some people who've got power
and other people
and the people who have the power they
make the rules
they decide what counts as right and
wrong and that's the way it ought to be
the strong get to rule the weak don't
get to rule
if you want to get the rule be strong
if you don't like somebody else telling
you what to do get some power yourself
at a very low level it's sort of like
when you were a kid and your mom or dad
said to you when you're under my house
my rules and then you said you say to
them i can't wait until i get my own
place and i'm at my own rules and when
you come in there's a comedian actually
says this the comedian says i'm going to
leave the refrigerator open all the time
just to
take my dad off you know i'm going to
run the air conditioner leave the door
open i'm going to leave the garage door
open so that you know people might come
by and take stuff
you know the idea there is when i'm in
charge
you do what i say and that's the right
way and when you're in charge
you won't be in charge because i'm going
to try to hold on to part of it if you
were in charge then you get to decide
and if you don't like it get your own
place
that's
you know that's one way to look at
through seminicus's position
might makes right
those who have the power get to decide
what counts as right and wrong
um
it's kind of a
tangled position
but it is a position a lot of people
hold isn't it um
so
where are the tangles let's look at some
of the other things he says
he says
justice is the
interests
of government
or the rulers
whatever is to their advantage
is just so if i'm in charge
not only should you do what i say you
should be looking out for me
it's kind of a
kind of a mentality that you would find
saying a mom right
those who are on top everyone else
should be working for their benefit
and they'll decide you know who else
benefits from it
he says
for subjects
to obey the rulers
is just
um
what else does he tell us about justice
this is when he's sort of giving us a
theory about justice
he says a few other things that don't
really jide with this if we mean the
same thing by justice
what does he think the
just person in the sense that you know
socrates or
paul marcus
would say is like yeah it's confusing to
me it should be it's okay that it's
confusing he ends up saying that
being just
makes you weaker yes
very good
justice is
weakness
it's also being
simple
or foolish
and
it's
unprofitable
if you're just you're a sucker
that's how you would say it these days
you're a dummy
you know if you're obey if you're
obeying the rules
uh because you're weaker than everybody
else yeah that's just
that's the right thing to do
but it's only the right thing to do
because those who have power can use it
on you
so let's think about policing for
example
is there any reason you should obey the
laws other than the fact that you'll be
punished if you don't
not according to thrasymachus
think about some of the laws that we
routinely obey and some of the laws that
we routinely break
how many of you break the speed limit
routinely
anybody here
doesn't oh
you still have some feelings about that
though right
is there sort of a level
that you shouldn't go past that
constitutes
say reckless driving like how many of
you feel that it's okay
in general
to drive about five to ten over but not
much more
interesting isn't it we have kind of a
convention
of breaking the law in the strict sense
but we also you know if somebody passes
us going 25 miles an hour
more than we are we said look at that
you know jerk
somebody should pull them over
and they should get a ticket
and but if we're driving along and the
cop pulls us over and we're going you
know 10 over the speed limit because
everybody is what do we say
why are you picking on me
you should have pulled over these other
guys they're all going over over it you
were driving over it yourself officer
those are ones that we often aren't
completely just when it comes to what
are some laws that we all do okay i hope
anybody murdered anybody recently
no
good
don't don't do it um
hopefully nobody plans to
um
now are you being a sucker
by let's say you're going to get in a
competition with somebody
you know for something valuable like a
promotion at work
if you were really ruthless what would
you do
yeah you could kill him or
maybe you don't have to kill him maybe
just put enough poison in to make him
make them stupid or
or you know
incapacitate them or something like that
to do that would be to be unjust
wouldn't it
but that would be
profitable
that would be according to through
semicons wise
that would be to be strong you'd be
imposing your own order on somebody
else
now if somebody even stronger than you
caught you doing that they'd punish you
but
that's okay for you through some case
because might makes right
those who have power get to decide what
counts
is right and wrong
this is a very radical point of view
thrasymachus
you're right there are some
inconsistencies with it and this is part
of what socrates is pointing out to and
we're going to look at one of those
arguments
in just a minute
but it's also an attractive point of
view a lot of people do hold this don't
they
this is a moral theory
you should probably watch out for people
who have a small theory you should
probably according to you know polar
marcus treat them as enemies because
they're probably going to treat you as
enemies
but it is a moral theory so we can't
talk about it as a coherent
point of view
and maybe you recognize yourself
or elements of yourself in this or other
people that you know
do you know some people who
talk like this act like this
have you run into people like that
i bet you have
i'm not going to ask you to name any
names but
let's look now at one way in which
socrates takes the wind out of
thrasymachus is sales
one thing i gotta say to you
if you
when you were reading through socrates
arguments and this back and forth with
with
polamarcus and with thrasymachus
if some of his arguments seem good and
some of his arguments seem weak
you're doing a good job
because plato has designed these
dialogues
in such a way that socrates does not
always make
the best arguments
when he's dealing with somebody who's
not as sharp and thrasymachus thinks
that he's really sharp but he actually
isn't
uh and polamarcus isn't really that
sharp either when he's dealing with
somebody who isn't quite as sharp
socrates will use some arguments that
have weak weak points to them
and if you're seeing that
and you're saying well you know somebody
could have said here this and how the
socrates have responded you're doing
exactly what plato wanted you to do as a
reader he designed these dialogues
as something like an obstacle course
not just to you know convey information
but to train your minds
that's why we've been reading them for
for over 2000 years
because that's what that's part of what
they do so if you if you saw some weak
points that's good congratulations you
are doing good if you didn't see the
weak points you know next time you read
through it
look and see whether socrates is kind of
pulling a fast one at certain points and
it takes a little while to recognize it
i don't catch all this stuff myself
the first time i've been reading these
for over 20 years i still sometimes
see new things
the argument that we're going to look at
has to do with
skills or
arts or
ways of knowing things
disciplines we could call them
think of your majors right
thracemica starts out by saying
justice
is the interest
of the stronger
and socrates you know kind of plays
around with him he says oh so you mean
that you know whoever is physically
stronger should rule like the wrestler
you know i think about wwe we don't wa
it's wwe now i think not wwf but
these big guys should they be the ones
that rule no it means those who actually
have political power
um
socrates raises the problem
if justice is what's in the interest of
the stronger
so the rulers
do rulers ever make mistakes about
what's actually in their own interests
well you know think about recent times
here in new york
can you think of any politicians that
have gotten themselves in trouble like
say in the last year
doing things they shouldn't do and then
had to resign their positions
anybody come to mind
yeah the aptly named guy right
was that really in his interest to send
dirty pictures of himself to
other people
he thought that you know something was
going on in his head and he thought that
was somehow a good thing to do
he seems to have been mistaken
so at least in that case
those who are ruling can can be mistaken
about what's in their own interests
do they make a lot of other mistakes
sure
you know politics is often pretty murky
and
a lot of times people think something is
good for them you know like just taking
a bribe good for you well in the short
term it is right because you get to get
a little money
get a nice gift or you know get to go
somewhere is take if you were a
politician is taking bribes a practice
that would really be in your interest in
the long term what do you think
what's probably going to happen to you
sooner or later
yeah you'll get caught and then what's
going to happen
yeah so it's really not in your your
best interest
so the rulers can be mistaken about that
so thrasymachus says something kind of
funny here
this is where he goes into the you know
socrates you need your nose wiped all
that sort of stuff but if you put that
aside
what does he say he says
you think that i mean
people who make mistakes no they're not
really rulers
you know the doctor when the doctor is
making a mistake he's not really a
doctor
the musician when the musician makes a
mistake he's not really a musician same
thing when the ruler is making a mistake
about his own interests he's not really
a ruler i mean the ruler who actually
as knowledge or
wisdom or the
art or skill
so thrasymachus isn't just saying
whoever's in charge gets to do whatever
they want and that's right
when he has to back up what he's saying
he says
i mean the person who really knows how
to run things well who knows
the art of ruling
some of you you know may
have taken classes like in public
administration or city planning or who
knows what else that would be similar to
this art ruling
now socrates has got him here
because what socrates is going to do is
he's going to attack
this notion that
the the ruler is actually first off the
stronger
and that the art of rule is just about
getting power and keeping power
and socrates is going to distinguish
he's not going to make a very strong
distinction but he's going to bring up
three different kinds of arts or
disciplines so there's arts or
disciplines like medicine right what's
the point of medicine
yeah to heal people right or to you know
keep them healthy or whatever and
medicine
ministers to the body um what's the
point of music the art of music
do you study music classes what what are
you actually aiming at hopefully
killing time
that would be another byproduct but
what are you studying music for
are any of you musicians
uh yeah you and what did you play you
played two instruments
flute and tuba so what are some of the
things that you have to do in order to
acquire the art of music
that were
tiresome onerous tasks scales drills
learn songs you didn't like
put up with teachers that you don't you
know particularly enjoy
what's the goal
what does that art produce
what are you aiming at when you're
doing all this work
well like it's like the final product
like when we put on our performances
yeah even if i don't like the song that
we're doing in a couple now i don't like
i know they're gonna sound really good
by the end yeah it's to produce beauty
something that will please other people
cooking
you know i mean you can you can go to
the store now and just you know pull
stuff off the shelf and
add water and
a little bit of butter you got mac and
cheese but if you want really good mac
and cheese you got to know what you're
doing right you have to know your way
around the kitchen what are you trying
to produce something that that's
particularly good and are you trying to
dominate other people
when you're cooking or making music or
doing medicine
the way that thrasymachus thinks the
rulers are trying to dominate people
not if you're a good musician i mean
there are some people who like you know
get into music and they join a rock band
because they they think it's going to
get them you know this this great life
of you know lots of drugs and girls and
money and and all that sort of stuff
which doesn't usually happen by the way
most most musicians are poor
and underfed
which is unfortunate but
there are doctors right some people get
into medicine
because they want to make money
really if you wanted to make money
if that's your only goal you shouldn't
study medicine you should study
something else like finance
you don't have to put in you know years
and years of medical school
and be somebody's essentially
indentured servant as a resident for a
while
maybe some people like to be doctors
because they like to lord it over other
people they like to be
ruling
is that a good doctor though
what makes a good doctor
yeah now notice this so if we want to
say let's say we use doctors as the
example
so the doctor
has
an art which is
medicine
right
and the doctor has patients
and in the doctor patient relationship
who gives who orders
do you give your doctor orders
get over here and prescribe me xyz
there are some doctors who will do that
they're not good doctors right
so the patient is actually the weaker
and the doctor is the
stronger aren't they in that
relationship
the musician who's producing beautiful
music
in a sense they're stronger than the
audience the audience can't do that
the audience has to sit there and listen
to the musician
but notice the stronger are they working
are they just doing whatever the hell
they want you know and making the week
or do their bidding
not if they're a good doctor
they're actually
listening to this patient tell them
about their problems
and you know like you said caring
about them they're
doing things in the interest
of the weaker
and if we go even further what about the
art
who's stronger and weaker in this
is the doctor stronger than the
art of medicine does the doctor get to
say
you know penicillin a lot of people say
that that's really good for
killing bacteria i don't think it is i
think i'm going to change the rules and
penicillin is bad now and instead i'm
going to give you a different kind of
mold
how would that work
what's that
bad yeah i mean people would die right
can a musician say
i don't really like
music theory
i think that um i'm just gonna play
whatever notes i feel like playing
and um screw the art of music and screw
my audience i'm gonna just you know jam
out how does that sound
that's usually what it's like when
somebody starts playing music
pick up a guitar and just
make a lot of notes
that doesn't work the art
is
stronger
and the practitioner
is the weaker
and what is the art concern with
is the art concerned with
itself with making itself stronger with
ruling everybody
it's concerned with the interest of the
weaker isn't it
the musician cares whether their
audience actually likes the stuff that
they're playing
and they have to practice hard so that
they can actually
do what the art allows them to do the
doctor actually has to study medicine
and medicine gets to call the shots so
that they can take care of the patient
socrates is saying it's the same thing
with removers
if you're really practicing the art of
ruling
then you're not the stronger the art
itself is telling you what you ought to
do
so let's take taking bribes again right
you're in charge you're the
judge in this area in the circuit court
and
you're actually doing some ruling you're
deciding cases you're deciding what
happens to people's lives and property
and how they should behave towards each
other and you're punishing people who
behave badly towards each other
and now you start taking bribes
the the art of
i guess we call it juris prudence
would say that's a that's a really
stupid thing to do
you're screwing up
it's in your interest i suppose to take
bribes in your short-term interest but
it's certainly not in the interest of
jurisprudence is it
and it's certainly not in the interest
of
the people that you're judging
and it's going to end up having bad
consequences it's going to fall apart
if you're if you're being a good judge
you take your your cues
from the art of jurisprudence and one of
the things that says don't take bribes
you have to treat each person fairly
every judicial caller says something
about not treating people
unfairly not playing favorites right
would you do that whose benefit do you
do that for
is it for your benefit i guess because
it keeps you out of trouble
but it's really for the benefit of the
as we call them the little people the
people who are being
ruled
so
if socrates is right
thrasymachus has got this
understanding of the art of rule or the
art of
making things work while
in society all wrong he's gotten mixed
up about it
where i'm going to leave you is think to
yourself could thracifications respond
to socrates there are some responses
that thrasymachus could have made
but he doesn't make because he's not
ready for the
the battle that he gets into
the other thing to tell you about the
pracinicas is
he sticks around he gets really
embarrassed but he sticks around through
the rest of the republic and he's
listening to socrates we find later on
in book six
that he hasn't left he's actually trying
to get some information on the soccer
case
let's look now
at one of the arguments that socrates
makes
to undermine thrasymachus and like i
mentioned if you see some weak points in
these arguments and there will be a
couple points where
thrasymachus could have said something
to socrates
but he doesn't have enough presence of
mind
to do that you're doing a good job if
you you can see weak points
one of the things that thrasymachus
talks about
and that socrates talks about is
what justice and injustice do
so thrasymachus says hey it's great if
you can be unjust or take power
that's that's the thing to do that's the
good you get to satisfy all your desires
everyone else has to cater to them
uh injustice is he says profitable it
pays off justice is not profitable it
doesn't pay off socrates says
okay let's think about this a different
way
we have a just person
and we have adjusted
richard then is going to try to take
advantage of of the other and take more
than his fair share
and uh
trying to get away with stuff
beyond jobs right
and
let's look at it like this now
let's not just think about it in terms
of just these two contrasts
let's think about it in terms of a
couple different possibilities
you got two just people
how are they going to act towards each
other are either one of them going to
try to overreach as he says that's the
term that gets used here try to take
more than his fair share or her fair
share
so okay so they're going to
get along right
uh why are they going to get along
because they both follow a sort of
similar
pattern of justice this is assuming of
course they agree what justice is
so
um
you know think about us you know i don't
kill you you don't kill me i don't steal
from you you don't steal from me
um when we're judging law cases if i'm
in charge i don't take bribes and that
way when i come up in front of you you
don't take bribes either and you give me
a fair hearing
what about the unjust person and the
just person
how's the how's the unjust person going
to behave
oh unjustly unjustly yeah that's good
they're going to try to take advantage
they're going to try to take more than
their fair share and the unjust person
might
get along at first but if the just
person is smart they'll realize hey this
person's unjust and they'll
become
an enemies right
the unjust person might get something
more out of it same thing over here
how are you going to work when you have
two unjust people
are they gonna get together and say hey
we're both unjust we got so much in
common with each other
how's that gonna work
it couldn't be it could be part of the
crime they could be we'll get that
stuff
how often
what will often happen though i think
they'll kind of fight against each other
to see who has the most power yeah
they'll both try to overreach each other
boost them
more on jobs
exactly
and neither one can really afford to be
weak in the face of the other because
neither one respects weakness right
so they're going to be
enemies to each other
so if you look at it this way here's the
outcomes for the just person
here's the outcomes for the unjust
person
which looks more profitable which looks
like a better set of outcomes
the unjust person's
got no friends
they're enemies with everybody they're
they're going to be at odds with
everyone
um like odysseus's
grandfather a topless who names the
medicis the man of all
odds right um tacos was this great thief
you'd steal anything that was nailed
down and people don't like that sort of
thing do they
they don't like getting things stolen
from them so they all treated him as
enemies
um i was just gonna say sometimes like
kids grow up in environments where they
have to choose to be unjust in order to
survive like gang violence you're right
yeah so they can when an unjust meets an
energized can certainly team up with you
very good very good so that takes us to
the to the next level
that that's an objection that you could
make to to this so
you know socrates doesn't actually
address that the way that you're
bringing it up
but through symmetrical could have said
to him hey hey what about this
what about you know thieves who get
together to pull off on a crime or gangs
or other organizations where
power is what's respected yeah i'm sure
it wasn't as life-threatening if you
didn't join you know then at least back
then obviously but like nowadays just
pockets of society but that's
pretty easy
um
well i mean criminal organizations have
been around in one form or another for a
very long time
and they didn't have
gangs in quite the same sense as we did
but in urban life
there would be criminal groups and if
you fell in with them
it was it was you know
conformed to their things and go along
with their
their um
injustices or
they'll kill you you know so
it's not completely different i mean we
have guns now it makes a lot more
dangerous
yeah
um
i think the short-term short-term lives
fans of feeds and things like that
are
like there's a sense of anonymity or
anonymity
but like afterwards
eventually i think what socrates is
trying to say is that eventually
you
like
the
the truth is that nobody in that group
is just they're all in just and they're
unjust in their ways so eventually
if there's someone's an attorney or
someone and there's no there's very huge
happy endings to
yeah you know
let's look at it like this this is kind
of a
abstract way of doing it so you could
have a band of thieves or you could have
like a large-scale criminal criminal
organization you could even have an
unjust state
you know a state that was trying to
dominate all the other
states taking over an empire or
something like that something like what
athens actually ended up becoming the
athenian democracy degenerated into they
called it the tyrant city because they
took over everybody else and the
spartans who were pretty tough and mean
and had their own you know sort of
power-dominated state they ended up
being seen at the liberators during the
polyphenesian war because the athenians
made themselves look so bad
now
if you have an unjust group like this
in relation to other groups they're
going to
they're going to behave badly towards
them and they might actually get
something out of it they take over
another country
they make those people slaves they make
them work for them they appropriate the
resources
they could dominate them commercially
there's lots of different things you
could do and also you know a criminal
organization against an individual
person
you know we have all these great
uh
action movies where you know arnold
schwarzenegger or sylvester stallone
or vin diesel or whoever fights the mob
and wins but that's not usually how it
goes it's usually
the organization wins over the
individual
and they do it by being unjust towards
them
how can here's the socrates question
we'll get to here's in just a second
how can this actually work though what's
one of the preconditions
there has to be some justice between the
individuals in there
or else it's going to break down
and actually we see this with gangs
a lot of gangs start out as
benevolent you know protective
associations they get corrupt they
become these criminal organizations
they're functioning pretty well for a
while what always does them in it's not
the federal government coming in and
crushing them they break down among
themselves they get too greedy they
can't get along with each other
they start competing over the same
territory they start disagreeing about
things
if you want to make this sort of thing
work you have to have and you have to
recognize justice to some degree
that's actually what what you just said
i was just going to point that out for a
criminal organization alas they would
have to have justice between another not
with others yeah so that's socrates
counter-argument is there a flaw with
that that you can see
what if you could just enforce terror on
everybody what if you you had an
organization where the top guy
or top girl whoever is
ruthless in charge
makes everybody fall in line with their
their idea of justice so nobody you know
nobody steals each other's stuff
nobody kills each other's soldiers
but they prey on everybody else could
that work
what do you think not for long but what
i suppose what were you gonna say
i was
i think
the idea is
that like the essence of being your
your id is unjust yeah
any amount of justice inside of that
doesn't
doesn't take away from the fact that you
are an unjust person and that eventually
you will ah
so if you're
if you're just with the people that
you're
interacting with yeah but your
organization is doing unjust things like
let's say you're in a military unit
and you're within your military unit
nobody cheats lies steals
from each other they're all you know
very good to each other but they're
doing more crimes
that would be wrong
even though you're being good without to
your fellow soldiers
they're still committing warfare yes
yeah
i mean if they lose the war then that's
justice right there if they end up
winning the war then and the war crimes
were committed during it yeah it's only
a matter of time i think before the
unjust polish
no
crumbles within themselves because they
find out what it's all based on
that's a really great segue now into the
last part of this
because
socrates
you may not have gotten this when you
read through it when he's talking about
this this problem of
the just versus the unjust
so we have
personal relationships
right so you've got two people the
justin the unjust person and how is it
going to work out for them and then you
have
societies
for
groups
they have to have some
degree of justice within themselves in
order to function if even if they're
unjust to each other
and then within the person themselves
within the human
being
we can talk about people being well
integrated or poorly integrated
and
an unjust person
part of the reason why they're going to
be unjust
from socrates point of view and i think
this is what you're getting at is why
people feel bad afterwards
they're not
entirely unified they're not entirely
integrated there's parts of them that
are warring with each other
i think you've all experienced the
condition of having
multiple desires that can't all be
satisfied at the same time and you feel
sort of like you're warring with
yourself like you're split this way in
this way
you've probably all experienced having a
bad
conscience about something where
you part of you is perfectly happy that
you got away with this thing but there's
a part of you that's also saying
that's not good you did the wrong thing
and you feel divided against yourself
right
the human being
what we count as justice
and injustice
in the human being
himself or herself
justice means all the
parts
of the soul parts of the personality
are
integrated
in harmony with each other
in agreement
um what would be
injustice the parts
are
warring or
possible to each
other or divide
at least in
what they're trying to get the person to
do
and the person won't be happy with
themselves
and the longer it goes on the more
profoundly unhappy they will be and one
way that you can try to integrate
yourself is by wiping out the other
parts of yourself that don't get along
some people try to do this some people
who want to be really tough do this they
try to wipe out the parts of themselves
that feel
tenderness mercy kindness towards other
people
because that that will feel better to
get rid of that and then you can just
have one main motivation
other people go the other way and they
they don't deal with the fact that we as
human beings we are aggressive creatures
we do feel hostility towards each other
and they suppress that and they're just
all kind and gentle and all that sort of
stuff
but then they start becoming passive
aggressive right you can see the
hostility coming out that's because they
don't have justice in their soul they
have injustice in it yeah
yeah i was going to say if we take like
mcintyre into account we're somebody
that keeps repeating and just actions in
our perception yes it will become a just
action at that point
so they will see it as a general right
on some level so that they they won't be
completely integrated okay and
eventually it will it'll start wearing
at them war criminals do end up having
usually having guilty consciences unless
they're just complete status some of
them you know never
never have any problem with what they do
yeah but even if they don't have guilty
consciousness like even if that's
i know i mean they can kill everybody in
the world and get away with it and
they're still going to need to take
their aggression out on somebody so
they're going to start willing
yeah
um
you're sort of making socrates point
which was going to get made again later
in before that
ultimately
justice and injustice in this stuff
is going to stem from having human
beings
who
have justice in their souls who actually
have thought through and worked out
their their moral problems and we don't
start out automatically good for
somebody like plate
we don't start automatically bad we
don't start automatically good we have
to be trained towards the good
justice has to be developed in our our
souls
so this is a good place to end
and we're going to pick up this
next class we're going to talk about the
ring of gaijins and egoism
and contract hearings